oh my God we were dying shy had no clue
who I was
a pants she yeah she peed her pants and
ran away
oh Dorothy that's horrible Kim
Kardashian pulls off an epic prank With
a Little Help from her daughter North
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot it all went
down on the latest episode of Hulu's the
Kardashians when northie gives her
famous Mama a major makeover mom doing a
regular nose or pig nose or a big nose
or small nose I'm so scared of a big
nose but we don't want a witch nose but
this one yeah I always try to find like
little things that each one of my kids
and I can do alone I have different
little activities and things that I do
with them North loves makeup she loves
special effects makeup she loves
Prosthetics and loves to do these pranks
of course Kim shares four kids with her
ex Kanye West nine-year-old North
seven-year-old Saint five-year-old
Chicago and four-year-old song I want to
make sure each kid gets so much of my
attention I think four is the perfect
magic number for me let's say you're in
my new artist
okay let's say I'm your new art teacher
is here to meet you this is the new art
teacher Annika she'll be around I just
wanted you to know her
hello I'm Andrew American to security
for that okay I guess North really
wanted me to meet you hi Monica she'll
be around just don't yeah Kim just
picked her up the street but we love her
she's a bit weird
yeah not only did they trick the
security guard they fooled North's
little sis shy too hey little girl come
here
I'm just gonna strip club
hi I'm Annika I do like my new art
teacher
North showed off her makeup skills
plenty of times before transforming into
her famous dad
thank you
and turning her mom into the Grinch
You're a mean one
Mr inch nice kid check your character
and a minion
[Music]
definitely loves makeup she loves a
before and after and Kim she says she
just loves seeing her kids having a good
time I just love making her happy
afterwards she said to me when we were
going to bed she's like Mom I just love
you so much
and I was just she's like I had so much
fun and like that is worth everything
worth looking like a you know like this
ridiculous person with a big nose
[Music]